what famous pop star is poised to play a
dc comics icon which sidekick is waiting
to star in his own film and is henry
cavill still superman here's everything
we know about all the upcoming dc films
we can't wait to see
dwayne the rock johnson has been keen to
play shazam nemesis black adam on the
big screen for years but ever since a
solo flick featuring the anti-hero was
officially confirmed in january 2017
details have been slight that changed at
the 2020 fandom when mr rock presented
some short video clips featuring concept
art for the film the first clip revealed
the film will stick to the character's
comic origins from his beginnings as a
slave to his rise as a powerful and
feared despot but it was the second clip
that got fans buzzing with the
revelation that the movie will introduce
the justice society of america to the
dceu the team which includes hawkman dr
fate cyclone and adam smasher seem
intent on helping adam achieve his goals
but does the anti-hero even want their
help former james bond actor pierce
brosnan will be playing dr fate while
noah centeno best known for starring in
to all the boys i've loved before will
portray adam smasher aldous hodge of one
night in miami will be hawkman and
quintessa swindell of trinkets will
appear as cyclone thirteen-year-old
bodhi sabangi will also show up in an
unknown role while uli let's kefu of
young rock will also play an important
part
after becoming a superhero in his 2019
film young billy batson will be taking
on some new bad guys in the sequel
shazam fury of the gods this time though
he'll get a little help from his foster
family whom he transformed into shazam
like heroes in the first movie to defeat
the evil dr savannah that movie's
mid-credits scene revealed savannah is
considering a team up with mr mind a
space worm from the planet venus we also
know that actress helen mirren is
joining the cast as a villainous
character named hespera the daughter of
atlas lucy lou will also be showing up
as hespera's sister calypso in addition
rachel zegler will be menacing the
shazam family as yet another daughter of
atlas shazam was a lot of fun but we all
know superhero sequels tend to go darker
it stands to reason then that whatever
hespera's evil plan is young billy is
going to have some growing up to do in
shazam too
aquaman has been the butt of jokes for
decades thanks to his seemingly lame
power set the very idea of an aquaman
movie used to be played for laughs you
treat me like i'm not even on the team
every day it's aqua loser this and
aquaponics that but then a funny thing
happened james wan's aquaman raked in
over a billion dollars worldwide and
became the highest grossing dc eu film
causing warner brothers to green light a
sequel aquaman and the lost kingdom will
see juan returning as producer and
director jason momoa patrick wilson
nicole kidman amber heard randall park
and yaya abdulmatine ii will also all be
back new characters will be played by
pilu azbek jani zao and vincent regan
along with india moore who will be
portraying a telepathic shark
interestingly the lost kingdom in the
title may refer to nekrus teleporting
underwater city from the comics that's
ruled by the tyrant king [ __ ] could
that be who ozbek is playing we'll find
out when the film splashes down in
theaters on december 25th 2023
the long-awaited solo film for ezra
miller's flash has been cooking since
long before the character's cameo
appearance in batman vs superman dawn of
justice while miller's multiple legal
problems have placed the film in
jeopardy test screenings have been
positive in fact the flash may end up
accomplishing the seemingly impossible
feat of uniting every dc property into a
single multiverse taking narrative cues
from dc's iconic flashpoint storyline
miller's scarlet speedster will be
racing through different realities
sparking crazy crossovers ben affleck
will reprise his role as batman but
michael keaton will also reprise his
version of the dark knight we saw in
1989's batman one of those waynes will
even design a brand new streamlined suit
for the flash the first teaser showed
what appears to be keaton's batmobile
and a look at two barry allen's one of
whom could be the reverse flash sasha
kaje who's set to star in a standalone
supergirl film also appeared in the
teaser standing alongside the two
berries in her full suit we've also
learned actor ron livingston will
replace billy crudup as henry allen due
to scheduling conflicts the blue beetle
name has been taken up by a few
different characters in the comics but
the upcoming blue beetle film will focus
on the most recent jaime is in the
comics reyes discovers the blue beetle
scarab by accident and takes it home the
artifact swiftly bonds with him and
grants him an extraterrestrial suit of
armor and a slew of powers to go with it
he's been part of several superhero
groups in the dc universe so a blue
beetle film could play into several
different ips cholo maradoena miguel
diaz on cobra kai will star is the
titular superhero he'll be joined by
bruno marquezin as jaime's girlfriend
penny and belisse esquero as his sister
george lopez will star as uncle rudy
while susan sarandon will play victoria
cord a character created specifically
for the film harvey guillen has an
undisclosed role while raul max trujillo
will play karapax the indestructible a
villain housed in a robotic body karith
danit alcocer who wrote the crime
thriller misbala will pan the screenplay
and angel emanuel soto will direct
following his work on charm city kings
blue beetle is currently set at theaters
on august 18 2023
inspired by the history of batman's
greatest foe director and co-writer todd
phillips reimagined the joker as arthur
fleck a struggling comedian suffering an
emotional breakdown as joker earned
multiple academy award nominations and
generated more than one billion dollars
in ticket sales a sequel was bound to
happen days after joker opened phillips
discussed future dc comics based films
with warner brothers chairman toby
emerick in june 2022 phillips posted a
photo of a script cover page on his
instagram account bearing the title
joker felia de we can also expect to see
joaquin phoenix back in the title role
when the film comes out on october 4th
2024 but you won't be alone as the one
and only lady gaga will be playing
harley quinn apparently she'll get to
sing too as the film is reportedly going
to be a musical
the green lantern corps movie has been a
long time coming and there may still be
a long road ahead both the dark knight
screenwriter david goyer and terminator
dark fates justin rhodes have been
attached to the project comics legend
jeff johns has been rewriting the script
since 2019 and while his work continues
there may be a slight complication
john's is also slated to contribute to
show runner greg berlanti's green
lantern series which is in the work for
the hbo max streaming service while
there's no word on whether the show will
connect to the green lantern corps movie
in any way it sure seems like that would
make sense at the moment no character or
plot details have been made available
for either the series or the movie
john's was to have delivered the first
draft of his script to warner brothers
by the end of 2019 so there may be some
forward movement on it soon it's even
been posited that jj abrams and his bad
robot production company might get
involved with the film it's worth noting
though that no green lantern projects
were announced in the initial unveiling
of the partnership for the time being
we'll just have to wait to see how the
long-awaited project shapes up
perhaps no piece of superhero news has
rocked the world of cinema like the
rumors that henry cavill will be
stepping down as superman in september
2018 news leaked that negotiations
between cavel and warner brothers had
broken down over a cameo in shazam
leading to the actor removing himself
from the role since then warner brothers
and cavill's own rep have insisted
cavill is still employed though the star
himself has played it coy with a bizarre
instagram video being his only public
response to the situation while a script
for man of steel 2 has been confirmed to
be in the works there's no telling how
this potentially massive shake-up will
affect the film's progress finding the
perfect superman is no small feat and
it's hard to imagine the studio moving
forward with this one if cavill really
needs replacing i will find him
if henry cavill does get replaced as the
man of steel stories surrounding a new
superman film suggest dc is taking the
superhero in a vastly different
direction tanahasi coates known for his
social journalism and runs on the black
panther and captain america comics is
penning the script jj abrams and his
production company by robot are attached
to the film but abrams isn't in the
running to direct instead dc and warner
brothers are looking for a black
director and a black lead actor rumored
directors include shaka king stephen
cable jr jd dillard regina king ryan
coogler and more actor michael b jordan
has already responded to rumors that
he'll be donning the cape saying he'd be
flattered but was just watching on this
one as far as the film's plot the
hollywood reporter reports that it might
be a 20th century period piece and that
kotz's version of superman is a kal-el
in the vein of the original superman
comics finally it's reported that this
film will be its own thing and not a
part of the existing dc extended
universe obviously these are early days
and there's a lot of speculation at this
point but keep your eyes peeled for more
on this new version of soups
the hbo max series titans has already
shown the transformation of batman's
former sidekick robin played by brenton
thwaites into the hero known as
nightwing and it's this version of the
character who has long been rumored to
be getting the feature film treatment
the project was first announced in early
2017 with the lego batman movie director
chris mckay slated to helm from a script
by bill dubuc since then however there's
been complete radio silence from warner
brothers mckay offered a glimmer of hope
for nightwing in late 2018 when he was
asked directly whether the feature was
dead and replied on twitter no you're
going to have to wait though keep hope
alive to paraphrase dick grayson
nightwing lives always mckay continues
to express hope that the film will make
it to production he hinted that
nightwing could be set in an alternate
universe or that it might see release
outside of a standard theatrical one
maybe going directly to hbo max warner
brothers has already shelved its
completed batgirl movie but we'll be
waiting with bated breath to see whether
dick grayson's solo vehicle actually
makes it to production you've trained me
well batman but from now on i make my
own decisions call my own shots
the idea of a feature film based on the
alien bounty hunter lobo has been
kicking around since before the dc eu
with a cancelled guy richie directed
version discussed as far back as 2009.
the project was revived as part of the
dceu slate in 2016 with san andreas
director brad payton set to helm with a
script by jason fuchs in early 2018 none
other than michael bay was rumored to be
taking the reigns with fuchs still
reported to be working on the script as
is becoming a theme with the dc eu
however the television side of things
has threatened to intervene the second
season of the sci-fi series krypton
features irish actor emmett j scanlon as
lobo leading some to speculate the
character's feature film prospects had
dimmed still there's been no official
word from warner brothers so a starring
vehicle for the ultra violent baddie
could still be in the cards once again
the name of the game is wait and see but
if there's one thing we know about lobo
it's that he never quits might take me a
week it might take me ten years but i'm
gonna bust out
dc nabbed an oscar winner for their
planned blackhawk film stephen spielberg
who has taken home three academy awards
will produce and likely direct a film
based on blackhawk the leader of an
international squadron of pilots who
take on the nazis during world war ii
the blackhawk character debuted in
1941's military comics number one and
was originally published by quality
comics before dc acquired it in 1956.
the character who was co-created by will
eisner bob powell and chuck quidera
headlined a number of best-selling
comics in the 1940s his world war ii
background makes him a great fit for
spielberg who earned an oscar for
directing the world war ii drama saving
private ryan spielberg is bringing on
indiana jones and the crystal skull and
jurassic park writer david kepp to pen
the script in 2022 four years after the
project got underway kep told collider
that while a script is written warner
brothers has yet to give the blackhawk
production a green light according to
the screenwriter there were a lot of
management changes at warner brothers so
i think we've just been kind of waiting
for that to settle down and for them to
decide what they want to do with their
dc universe
the dcu's current version of superman
may be up in the air but one project
warner brothers is reportedly high on is
a starring cinematic vehicle for his
cousin supergirl the character is
already enjoying a high profile thanks
to the success of her cw tv series and
the time seems right for the dc eu to
introduce another powerful female lead
actress sasha kaje who beat out hundreds
of other auditioners will be dceu's
supergirl kache's only major role to
date is on the young and the restless
but she'll make her debut as cara zorel
in the flash before taking to the skies
in supergirl little is known about this
in development project other than its
screenwriter oren uzil who penned the
cloverfield paradox the rumor mill has
suggested the project could be set in
the 1970s in an alternate timeline where
cara arrives on earth before her cousin
this would set the film version of the
character apart from her tv incarnation
uzil has been at work on the script
since august 2018 so more details are
sure to surface
dc is looking to bring a little magic
into its cinematic universe the studio
is aiming to put zatana zatara a
powerful magic user into her own feature
film considering some of the other
projects being floated around the dc
universe such as justice league dark
zetana's debut fits perfectly into dc's
current plans the project is very early
in development but one important detail
has been confirmed emerald finnell the
writer of the academy award-nominated
film promising young woman has been
tapped to write the screenplay in an
interview with empire fennell said she's
excited for the scales zatana gives her
to work with and she can't wait to write
something quite dark that's also big and
scary since it's so early we don't have
any casting information yet surrender
swan played zatanna in the cw show
smallville but since that series wrapped
up over a decade ago it seems unlikely
she would be cast as the lead of the new
film
birds of prey introduced us to quite the
crew of dc anti-heroes though it mainly
gave margot robbie's harley quinn a
chance to fly solo it also introduced us
to updated takes on black mask huntress
victor zazz and black canary the last
one apparently made a good impression as
actor journey smilet has been tapped to
reprise her role in her own solo film
wanna hear a secret
[Music]
while still very early in development we
do have an idea who's going to help
bring a black canary movie to life
smollett will be reuniting with
lovecraft country creator misha green
who's penning the script black canary is
also being produced by sue kroll of
crowling co entertainment who also
produced birds of prey the film is in
development for an hbo max release
suggesting it'll be smaller in scale
than the pillar dc eu movies involving
the justice league
fans of early 2000's animation might
remember the static shock series which
aired on kids wb for four seasons based
on the milestone comics character virgil
hawkins is a 14 year old boy who gains
electrical and magnetic powers after a
freak accident and becomes the superhero
static during the 2021 fan dome event a
static shock movie was confirmed to be
in development with randy mckinnon
pending the script reginald hudlund is
overseeing the relaunch of milestone
comics is also working behind the scenes
in addition michael b jordan's
production company outlier society is
helping to bring the film to life in
october 2020 jordan told the hollywood
reporter i'm proud to be a part of
building a new universe centered around
black superheroes our community deserves
that outlier society is committed to
bringing to life diverse comic book
content across all platforms and we are
excited to partner with reggie and
warner brothers on this initial step
dc is starting to dig deeper into their
bag of tricks for characters they want
to build films around and their latest
offbeat choice is our men there have
been multiple characters who've taken up
that mantle but they all center around a
chemical formula that grants the user
incredible abilities for one hour we've
actually seen several versions of our
man in the cw's arrowverse patrick j
adams played rex tyler the original hour
man on legends of tomorrow while lou
ferrigno jr played the character on star
girl cameron gelman played rex's son
rick tyler on star girl and took on the
our man mantle himself however it
remains to be seen what direction dc
will go with the hour man film the
screenplay is being tackled by gavin
james and neil widner chernin
entertainment which also developed the
most recent planet of the apes franchise
is producing the film alongside dc and
warner brothers
wonder woman is regarded as one of the
dceu's best efforts and director patty
jenkins says there are plenty more
stories to tell about diana's amazon
sisters dc is currently working on a
spin-off about these warrior women and
while the details are scarce jenkins has
said the spin-off will focus on events
that occur after diana leaves themsira
she also said the story would help
bridge the gap between wonder woman 1984
and diana's third film that seems to
indicate that the spin-off will be
released before the in development
wonder woman 3. jenkins will not be
directing this spin-off but she is
involved in the film's creative
development as a producer we expect
other amazons to reappear but details
remain tightly wrapped up at this point
unlike wonder woman 1984's hbo max
release wonder woman 3 will have a
traditional theatrical release and is
expected to be a concluding film to the
trilogy during 2021's fandom writer
director patty jenkins also revealed
that original wonder woman linda carter
will be returning as amazonian warrior
asteria that said it could still be a
long while before we get to finish the
story of diana prince jenkins and star
gal gadot are working together on the
historical drama cleopatra and jenkins
has been tapped to direct star wars
rogue squadron which is scheduled to
come out in christmas 2023. gadot is
attached to about a half dozen other
projects as well in other words it's
going to be a while but we'll eventually
get to see another wonder woman movie on
the big screen